what are we doing Smurfs yes did fuck
didn't even do what you did you just
turn to me okay what are we doing we're
doing this I like that that was our
intro hey I add something better planned
if it was a good suggestion that was not
um okay so apology for kind of the
different angle people though CD you're
gonna nuts now but yeah there's like no
light today I'm sitting on the opposite
side confused
everything's moved around uh so I yeah
we're gonna talk about Smurfs cuz I was
just looking through it like you know
popular videos on YouTube and stuff and
first it gets a lot of hits on this but
man and after coming off a patch Adams
we talked about that move it I what does
one say about Smurfs well there's also a
new one coming out uh that looks like
it's at least sticking closer to kind of
what it is they're not bringing into
like modern day and do Patrick Harris
isn't there okay I will let me just get
the jump on you here that is how bad
this movie was not even Neal fucking
Patrick Harris could save it not even
him um and yeah you know some of these
names you keep seeing over and over like
you know how when you're young and
you're seeing you know you start to see
Tim Burton and Danny Elfman like oh I
I've seen these names over and over
here's trying to see Steven Spielberg oh
I'm seeing these names over and over you
connect to the good stuff yeah just
really good names you associated with
bad stuff you don't really pay attention
but you're like I'm seeing his name Raja
Gosnell pop up a lot um and uh I'm at a
point where I want to just believe
that's a fake name real sounds like it's
just like it's like whoever that guy is
even he's is like I I don't want my name
on this it's you know just I'm gonna
make up a fake name but you know yeah
yeah it's one of those were you kind of
like yeah you see it and you go so what
we do right yes
do I think Beverly Hills Chihuahua I
think something like that uh in back
maybe Inspector Gadget like you know
some of these uh I try heaven right here
he direct this I'm so curious uh he oh
no he did not that that was a David girl
the hook for that one yeah my bows think
I didn't I don't know but we say well
that guy's name David Kellogg like the
breakfast cereal yeah and the guy that
said you masturbate you'll go blind um
fun fact this is so um yeah this is a
movie that like honestly you don't have
much to go off of anyway uh you know cuz
Smurfs is like keep for kids whatever
remember do you really do with I just
remember when I was a kid they had a
movie called it was like Smurfs in the
Magic Flute yeah and then invented some
carve some wooden Magic Flute or
something that made people dance and it
was silly and ridiculous but it's very
stupid it was aimed at five-year-olds
and I was like that was perfectly
acceptable why do we need to spend
millions of dollars on something to
bring them to you know New York and have
Neil Patrick Harris in it and and Hank
Azaria just just just slumming it just
warming it no I won't may go a little
bit I hold the fan Hagar's area oh no
he's not he's been trying he's not like
he's given nothing he's not slumming it
but he is let he is left hung out to dry
yes like you he is literally just
dangled over fighting for his life and
they they dropped him into the shark pit
yeah it which is a shame cuz the makeup
on him is it looks like Gargamel yeah it
looks like him I don't think he sounds
like him but it's kind of like okay just
go along with whatever he's doing and
it's like even if he wanted to make it
CGI it's just like you could have just
kept it there in the Smurfs village I
don't know why why New York it yeah it's
always man York why is it always New
York yeah okay zo York you're not the
center of the fucking universe all right
I know you think you are but God well
and there's something to you know with
you know the Smurfs it's like it as they
even say are doing your name's not tie
into your personality it
personalities come first into the names
and they go yes and it's like all right
that's a cute joke but it's one of those
things where it's not like ooh you know
what I'd really like to see I like to
see Smurfs in modern time think of the
crazy possibilities it's like there
aren't any what can you do with this
there's nothing you can do it was meant
to be just some charming little kids
thing and then they do what they always
do it's like well let's make it hip
let's crap it up was just totally crap
it up
they can't have too did too did yeah
well they shat in the Hat that's do we
dare go as far as they can that no no I
can have way worse no oh
Murph's is mostly harmless at least as
terrible as it is can the Hat i fat
birds I think it kills Angels I think
every time somebody watches it edgy
angels die I think it's part of that
like heavenly war between heaven and
hell and yeah it's part of some demonic
thing and yeah so this was a time where
that was always the thing you know like
something from the past is brought to
modern day New York and that was just a
really popular genre really it just kind
of became a genre and decide to do with
Smurfs and we can say it sucks all we
wanted stuff but it was a big hit and I
think part of it is that like obviously
not that much money went into the film
because they don't look that good or
anything so I pity it at the word Smurfs
on it what no I was gonna say uh the
advertising was everywhere I mean you
couldn't get away from this damn thing
it was on like every billboard right
buzz yeah we tried hard and didn't work
I get well okay and that works for kids
I guess that's up but it's no indication
of quality I always kind of say like you
know remember like with cuz I cuz as an
adult seeing all the ads for Smurfs made
me want to not only not see it but track
down every theater that was running it
and blow it up in the middle of the
night with nobody in it but blow it up I
kind of feel like remember when we were
talking about like the OO girls from
like the chipmunks from you and stuff I
always kind of said like you know it's a
mix of like you know on top of little
kids you know it's a mix of
that and then like you know the 50 is 60
year old ladies you know or like the
middle-aged laser just like oh don't you
I see you now look you it looks so cute
it's like people who want to you because
there's cute because it's cute and
nothing else this is the movie that was
literally made for grandparents to take
their grandchildren to because those are
the only two demographics and all the
people who are just like wow I can't
believe they make these things come to
life because the last film they saw was
probably King Kong and five energy I
hate this movie oh and but not but you
know I'll talk about two languages
Thanksgiving and what can I say Audrey
but we're all miserable it's it's one of
the things where it's like you know that
crowd of like not that they want to see
it ironically but they kind of do I can
read these girls grown up in high school
okay you're see space dude come on this
body bugs body Michael sure I'll be cool
and they hi gentle they do a lot of CIA
sauce oh no no no but I'm talking about
like the people that want to go see them
or like yeah people all go see the movie
so that's like just what it'd be fun
what do you find on the text throughout
the whole movie and and Targ and stuff
like they're not at you there to see the
movie they're there to have something on
you know while they text and talk I feel
like we're doing girls a disservice when
we do that because how many like cool
girls nerd girls tomboy girls got
gonorrhea girls would look at these
films be like that looks like Sean ahh
I'm talking about like cuz I knew these
girls growing up they were kind of like
kind of the popular girls they had like
you know uh
okay so idiots so you knew some idiots
growing up there were couple they were
smart not Maddie and I didn't know them
but I'm sure they were statistically
that would be possible you know you're
not making your case no but but you know
what I'm talking about I me is sort of
like there's people watching it cuz when
that be cute you know like they don't
want to you cuz hey I want a good movie
it would that be cute if we saw it those
kind of kids and then people who say
would that be cute you know I I just
want Flum I want nonsense and I feel
like fluff can be done
I never dated any of this beam and I
didn't care to get to know them it's one
of those things where it's like you know
fluff can be done well you know like
storks we saw that we loved that movie
but that was actually a good mom kind of
but I mean like in terms of like because
the reviews were like was it like 60% or
something I'm like why the hell Billy
get like 60% and we're saying cuz it's
not changing anything it doesn't have
any huge more or lessen that's gonna be
like Pixar's I'm like that it's just a
good comedy and I sort of think mommy
always it is lower on the totem pole
anyway among screen yeah unless it's
trying to change the world to how and
that's not fair sometimes a comedy can
just be a comedy and it could be flop I
think storks is great flop that's
written fantastically and is super super
funny but birth stuff not a comedy it's
a documentary on how to not make a movie
and what what I like cuz I feel like
this was going on for a while and I feel
like it's died down but there was like a
long period of time we're sort of like
that I'm trying out what I called it
let's start like the hypnosis for kids
just the constant movement where they're
you never feel the impact you never feel
like anything is hitting it's just
seeing these things move and truth and a
message it's the one
mosha it's the music to the music I was
a kid like every single movement we were
and even Warner Brothers cartoons still
have silence occasionally or pauses or
breaths or breaks in the music it just
feels like autopilot like when you know
they it's like you put on autopilot and
the kids are just going on and they're
not gonna laugh they're just gonna look
at it because it's movement uh I think
movement porn is what I call it's just
movement porn um because if you just
like seeing things move like that that's
what you might as well just be high and
watch it cuz it's the same kind of
movement that may have been the other
Democrats yes true yeah
wolf blew it I could see under my head
doc you imagine dropping acid during
that film now whoa oh yeah or pounding
some absinthe ripe of it yeah just
thinking of seeing up just just saying
Hank Azaria on acid no thanks
dis man sit there tripping balls Wow
guards coming at me that freaky ass cat
yeah man that cat was aa special talk to
no good yes well apparently is a boy ah
you find out that you a boy cat even
though he has a girl's name uh what was
it Azrael I think so yeah I didn't watch
the show that much as your neutral name
I thought that was some demon like named
Jessica yeah I don't know I I'm not sure
that I think that's a kind of a
gender-neutral like I don't know si
probably not to be you know in place of
finger after that but um yeah like a
gene a gene is a gender nude like that
girl named gene you could have a boy
named gene and yeah got it
yeah I'm sorry I probably running I'm
reelin of the specifics for you Smurfs
it's the only thing I can figure so many
people clicked on our review of it that
there must have been just that hatred
that we had to because they made a
sequel I was also hit but then they
stopped it's like I'm sure I make sense
no with the chipmunks they just kept
going and going you know but with Smurfs
they stopped it too and I found that
interesting uh you know I think they do
the same thing with scooby-doo they
started early too far well yeah we
talked about the Smurfs um oh you know I
forgot to the the celebrities too isn't
keep Harry in this - oh this party
welcomes you more that she wore that
Smurf dress all are ugly why yes Hank
Azaria Neil Patrick Harris I remember
nothing I don't even remember the plot I
didn't remember what Neil Patrick Harris
did what did he do what do they always
do an office job reason and executive
always advertising
it's always an office job in New York
and somehow he has an amazing place that
you could never afford in reality when
to be fair being an exact pays good
money but you're it's still New York
it's fucking New York um yeah doesn't
seem good at his job
right cuz that was also the Alvin the
chipmunk sing it's like what is it like
wasn't it perfectly now that chipmunk
she wants definitely yeah just like oh
he's having
you know music she's throwing out his
stuff and everything I was like help you
before that house just realized it was
like no plot well what did you among her
Smurfs either of them but I'm just like
what was it was Neil Patrick Harris was
doing things and Smurfs showed up and
did things and then things got Rizzo and
they left it's like you know what I'm
happy with my things and that was the
thing you know and if you explain that
to a child they would probably just not
and agree with you that that's what it
was yeah that's right um yeah they
Jonathan winters greatest performance um
he was in that yeah oh he's Papa Smurf
it was his best performance sensor oh
that's right I see I forget I this is
like there's some movies like patch
Adams is interesting cuz it angered me
for all the right reasons I can remember
the Smurfs is one of those films where
it just angers me in a way it's kind of
easy to forget I'm just angered because
I can t remember sitting through it it's
like Tim Burton's Alice in Wonderland
I'm like the second and low house and
one oh I really pissed me off I was
shocked and I left the cinema the second
I walked outside and the Sun shone in my
face again I'm like what the hell just
happened I had no memory of the movie I
just saw
I love Alison one or last why that won't
piss me off um well I didn't love the
Smurfs to begin with I was completely ya
know like I could sort of see you at
this one I said I watched him as a kid
so I had that attachment but I was never
attached enough to them as a kid that
I'm just like how dare you with the
swerve says but at the same time that
just means it's it's a memorable I
remember the pasta more than I remember
the show you're a Smurfs pasta with
meatballs no if you get three Smurfs on
your spoon you win cuz pasta was a game
back then you know it's really weird
even by the low bar that we set for
ourselves being like five years old you
still a shit oh yeah no no that was Chef
Boyardee that was this guy kept Chef
Boyardee business for like ten years
now what though single-handedly prop the
company
the name because that's what people said
after having it they want chef boy nor
me and that's how that knows a ship our
man oh yeah but I do remember that how
it was always a game just like a
tic-tac-toe apposite I get the edges you
get three in a row and you win you win
what your whole a pasta who are you
playing against the other player I'm so
lonely
against the empty cans like pasta
solitaire oh yes yeah we're talking
about shit Boyardee now so not
interesting this movie is um do you
think they can have you seen the trailer
from the new Smurfs at all no this this
one so is wrecked the sperms as I know
it that I never want to see another
Smurfs film again yeah just her son it
just looks like whatever cute adventure
whatever it looks like I guess what it's
supposed to be but it's like yeah I also
start look down like you know what what
are really the possibilities from this
idea they live in mushrooms that's a
little creative but that's about it I
don't remember any other like this de
France to be made the song I remember
the song um and yeah that's about it I
think Gargamel is the most interesting
part of that show like I actually look
forward to seeing him because I'm like
okay something's got a half I think
Gargamel used alchemy to live through
the ages and then kept creating like
cybernetic enhancements as the century
went on and then he became dr. qua and
that's the same cat maybe I'm just
trying to figure out a way to tie it in
a full metal alchemist like well wasn't
what the names a little kid that was in
the armor oh uh yeah like maybe he gave
him the arms like the metal arms could
be transmute the soul into the middle
one no cuz yeah alters the voice dr.
claw would have had to do a
transmutation where he lost his arm so
we had to get an auto mail arm um
probably to save the cat hmm yeah but
then the cat got transformed into like
you know it's kind of like the cute
little girl but in Reverse somehow maybe
he gets transformed it's like this
mutated girl or
something like that you know there's
gadget a homunculus that'd be kind of
cool man we wish you reread inspector
get pennies Winry that goes without
saying things together and everything
but god damnit this will be so
uninteresting haha derailed your thought
yeah I really thought I'd have a little
bit more to talk to many of your train
of thought it's just like Amtrak now
yeah it is just so dull it's just a dull
dull movie um I don't know what else to
say about it except I just can't think
at some point we gotta do Smurfs - I
know that oh why because the first one
was such a hit and I mean people loved
seeing us do it I just hope when we do
the second one there's just one but
that's the price we have to pay we'll do
it but the real thoughts gonna fucking
suck yeah this as bad as this gem is
this one we're not going about like you
know fucking skittle I do cos man
instead we're seeing in the trailer
there's kind of like punk Smurfs they're
like grey and they have like dyed color
hair and they're like with attitude whoa
I don't know but that's got to be
something what uh um I don't know why do
we need punk Smurfs why do we need smart
at all